we're going to look at the most
fundamental of all mathematical data
types namely sets and let's begin with
the definitions so informally a set is a
collection of mathematical objects and
the idea is that you treat the
collection of objects as one new object
and that's a working definition but of
course it really might help a little bit
but it's a circular definition this is
not math yet because I haven't defined
what a collection is in a collection is
no clearer or easier to define than a
set is so let's try to work up the idea
of of sets by looking at some examples
so we've already talked about some
familiar ones there's the real numbers
for which we had this symbol are in a
special font and the complex numbers C
and the integers Z and we might have
mentioned and you might have seen
already the idea of the empty set for
which we use this symbol that looks like
a 0 with a line through it let's look at
an example to pin things down let's look
at this set of 4 things namely it's got
two numbers PI over 2 and 7 a character
string in quotes Albert R and the
boolean value true so those are the four
different things in it they're of mixed
type and you might not like to have a
mixed type like this in a programming
language but mathematicians don't worry
about such things very much readily
anyway the first observation is that
though the order in which these elements
are listed doesn't matter this set where
the braces indicates that it's a set of
these things is the same if I listed T
first then the string and the two
numbers last there is no notion of order
in a set now to a computer scientist
this is a little unnatural the most
natural thing to be would be to define a
sequence of things like the the sequence
that began with 7 then had the character
string then had the number then had the
boolean and you can get by with working
with working with lists of things as
long as they're finite but they very
quickly get out of hand when you have to
talk about say a set of lists then it's
not clear how to make a list out of
those and you wind up needing sets again
so sets in fact are an unavoidable kind
of idea so another basic thing to
understand about the notion of a set is
that an element is either in a set or
not in a set like so if I write down 7
PI over to 7 this is the same
description of the same set that a 7 PI
over 2 I'm just telling you the same
thing twice here that 7 is in the set
and the 7 is in the set again so no
notion of being in the set more than
once now it sometimes technically you
want to add a notion of so-called multi
sets in which elements can be in a set a
certain number of times an integer
number of times but there's no real need
for that it's a secondary idea and from
our point of view you're in or out of a
set if you repeat elements it's the same
as mentioning them once so the most
fundamental feature of a set is what's
in it and for that there's a special
notation so we'll say that X is a member
of a where a is a set and use this
epsilon symbol to indicate membership
it's red X as a member of a so for
example PI over 2 is a member of that
set that we saw before that had PI over
2 in it 14 over 2 is also a member that
said because 14 over 2 is just another
description of 7 when I write 7 here I
don't mean the character 7 I mean the
number 7 and so 14 over 2 is this
description of the same number it's in
that set on the other hand PI over 3 is
a number that's simply not in that set
so I'm using the epsilon with a vertical
bar through it or some kind of a line
through it to mean not a member of
number ship is so basic that there's a
lot of different ways to say it besides
using the membership symbol X is a
member of a you can sometimes say X is
an element of a or X is in a as well as
X is a member of a they're all synonyms
so for example 7 is a member of
the integer Z is our symbol for the
integers 2/3 is not a member of the
integers because it's a fraction that's
not an integer and in the other hand the
set Z of integers itself is a member of
this three element set consisting of the
truth value T the set of all integers
and the element 7 so here's an example
where a set can contain sets quite big
ones even and that's fine
we just [ __ ] that's not any problem
mathematically related to membership is
another fundamental of subsets so a is a
subset of B it's pronounced so that
horizontal you with a line under it is
meant to resemble a less than or equal
to symbol so you can think of it as
being a as less than or equal to B but
don't overload the symbols less than or
equal to is used on numbers and other
things that we know how to order and
this is an upper a relation that's only
allowed between sets so a is a subset of
B a synonym is that a is contained and
basically means that every element of a
is also an element of B and if I wrote
that out in predicate logic notation as
a predicate formula I'd say for every X
X is in a implies X is in B if it's in a
then it's in B everything in a is in
vain so some examples of the subset
relation or that the integers are a kind
of an integers or is a special case of a
real number so the set of integers is a
subset of the real numbers a real number
is a special case of a complex number so
the real numbers are a subset of the
complex numbers and here's a concrete
example where I have a set of three
things 5 7 & 3 and this is the set with
just the element 3 in it know we
sometimes are sloppy about
distinguishing the element 3 from the
set that consisting of just 3 as its
only element but in fact it's a pretty
important distinction to keep track of
in this case 3 is not a is not a subset
of this set on the right but the set
consisting of 3 is a sub
set of the set on there on the right
because after all the only member of
this set is three and that is a member
of this set a consequence of this
general definition is that every subset
is a subset of itself because everything
in a is in a that's not really very
interesting
another important general observation is
that the empty set is a subset of
everything the empty set is a subset of
every set let's look at why that is in
more detail so the claim is that the
empty set is a subset of everything let
B be any old set then the empty set is a
subset of B what exactly does that mean
according to the definition of subset
well it says that everything that's in
the empty set if it's in the empty set
then it implies that it's in B for every
element if it's in the empty set then
it's in B well what do we know about
this the assertion that X is in the
empty set is false no matter what X is
there's nothing in the empty set and now
I have an implication and implies where
the left-hand side the hypothesis is
false that means that the whole
implication is true and it doesn't
depend on what B is I'm not even gonna
look at B I can see that X is in empty
set is false so the whole implication is
true and so what I'm saying is that for
everything every X something that's true
has to be true well it is and that's why
the empty set is a subset of B satisfies
this definition in a formal way and this
is an example of why that convention
that false implies anything is
convenient and is made use here so when
you're defining sets if they're if
they're so small you can just list the
elements and as we did with that set
with seven and PI over two and Albert
are sometimes we can even describe
infinite sets as some kind of a list
like I might describe the set of of of
integers as saying well it's 0 1 minus 1
2 minus 2 and so on and you'd understand
that but in general what if
describing a set that it's not so easy
to list say the real numbers then what
I'm going to do is define a set by a
defining property of in the set so I'm
interested in a property P of elements
and I'm going to look at the set of
elements X that are in some set a such
that P of X is true and that's how we
that's the notation we'll use so this
would be read as the set of X in a such
that P of X holds that X has property
pay so notice this vertical bar is read
as such that it's just a mathematical or
a deviation this is those elements in a
that have property pay that P of X holds
for that defines a set of those elements
let's look at a simple example the set
of even integers is simply the set of
numbers n that are integers such that n
is even so in this case the property P
of n means that n is even one last
concept is the concept of a power set
rule so the power set of of a set a is
all of the subsets of a so we could
define it using set notation as it's the
set of B such that B is a subset of a an
example would be let's take the power
set of the two boolean values true and
false so the power set of true and false
of that set consisting of two elements
is well what are some of its subsets the
set consisting of just true is a subset
of true truthful so is the set
consisting of false and so is the whole
thing it's a subset of itself and one
final element the empty set is a subset
of the set of boolean values true and
false so the power set of this two
elements set is a set that has four
things in it one two elements of size 1
1 element of size 2 1 element of size 0
and that's gonna be a general phenomenon
that we'll examine more later how big is
the power set of a set the even numbers
a that we just defined on the previous
slide is a member
of the powerset of Z because it's a
subset of integers even integers are a
special case of integers and the
integers are a member of the power set
of R this is just a synonym for saying
that integers are a subset of reals
every integer is a real so the integers
are a subset of reals which means
they're a member of the power set of
reals so the general property is that a
set B is a member of the power set of a
if and only if B is a subset of a that
was the defining condition for power set
and that's a fact to remember and it may
potentially confuse you but it's a good
exercise to keep in keeping track and
the difference between is a member of
and is a subset of